because that first freshman cover was
cool it was cool great artist on there
but it wasn't like really a thing until
the second one hit second one hit it
changed the game
um because the first one as as great as
i thought it was a great cover
but it didn't do too well it was like
crooked eye joel ortiz lupe lupe was
boozy on there lucy was on it yeah
um
saigon yep pap it was a couple people on
it the thing about it was like the game
was changing from the streets to the to
the internet
and when dayton thomas got there he was
like i want to do a freshman cover and i
want to cover the blog the people who
was big on the blogs
they said hell no
and he was he fought and fought and
fought and made it happen because the
last one didn't sell well when we did
that one that's like the top selling
that was one of the top selling
magazines yeah because it was you asher
roth wale
b.o.b b.o.b charles hamilton corey cory
guns
every time i hear charles hamilton's
name i just i have such a big fan and
free charles he's locked up right now oh
is he [ __ ] yeah cory guns was ace hood
on there they said
cudi cuddy currency wow and blue
wow yeah that's a crazy cover that's a
crazy cover